good day everyone happy New Year and
welcome I'm Jack Van Horn from the
University of Virginia and I'm very
proud to welcome you to this edition of
our 2023 2024 foundations of biomedical
data science seminar series the lecture
series is supported by uva's integrated
translational Health Institute of
Virginia the College of Arts and
Sciences the UVA School of data science
and through a grant from the National
Institutes of General Medical Sciences
since 2016 the foundation's of
biomedical data science seminar series
is focused on the use of data science
methodologies artificial intelligence
deep learning and statistical modeling
as they pertain to differing themes in
the biomedical and Health Sciences our
theme for this year is focused on
building Partnerships for generative AI
training in biomedical and clinical
research where every Friday we enjoy
presentations from a wide range of
leading thinkers about the issues
promise and opportunities and hurdles
associated with the emerging um notion
of AI based methods applied to
biomedical science data types indeed we
would like to welcome everyone and uh
remind them that they are welcome to uh
apply for our 2023 2024 application
cycle Junior faculty are strongly
encouraged to uh who are working in
areas such as development of generative
AI methods applied to biomedical
research and those Junior faculty
actively utilizing AI in their
biomedical teaching to consider applying
we find that this is a very exciting and
engaging program which brings together
uh AI platform developers and University
level Educators uh to better understand
the power promise and potential perils
associated with generative AI
participants selected for our biomedical
data science Innovation lab program will
leverage these seminar presentations um
as vital material for a culminating
iners manuscript and Grant project
development Workshop to be held at the
bajia beachfront Resort located in Sunny
San Diego California in June of 2024
today I am very excited to welcome our
speaker Rafael Alvarado from the
University of Virginia Dr Alvarado is an
associate professor and the academic
General faculty in the school of data
science at the University of Virginia
where he is the director of the
humanities data science collaboratory he
earned his PhD in cultural anthropology
and has been a career-long digital
humanist his research interests include
textual analytics the anthropology of AI
and the history of data science in
continuing our 2023 2024 biomedical data
science Innovation uh lab and uh seminar
series theme Dr Alvarado's lecture today
is entitled language knowledge and llms
in the context of biomedical data
Science Education he will describe that
all branches of scientific knowledge are
duly constructed as formal uh or for
formally ordered bodies of knowledge and
informally shared understandings of the
world and how things are done both of
these forms are highly mediated through
language and discourse through the
development of formal ontologies and
vocabularies used to organize
information through in formal modes of
speech that characterize communication
between members of a knowledge community
the deployment of large language models
in the context of biomedical science
impacts both of these forms of language
and the and knowledge as well as their
relationship to one another Dr alado
will talk about um uh providing a
framework for making sense of the
changes that llms have had and are
having and likely to have on biomedical
knowledge as always we are streaming
this lecture live and for recording via
YouTube if you're watching on YouTube
thank you so much for joining us also
our specially selected 2023 202 for
biomedical data science Innovation lab
participants as well as alumni are
encouraged to submit any questions via
the chat feature in their YouTube
sessions I will synthesize all of these
questions I will ask them on your behalf
during the last 10 minutes or so of the
lecture and with that welcome Raph I am
very excited to hear your presentation
and we look forward to having a little
chat at the end thank
you thank you for the kind introduction
Jack and uh good morning or good
afternoon everyone depending on which
time zone you're on uh I'm speaking from
San Francisco this morning um so let me
begin uh with the SE from what you just
said about providing a framework I'm
going to begin with a quote that I that
I've always liked uh there is nothing so
practical as a good theory Kurt lean and
this is uh to to Stave off any of the
empiricists in the audience who think
that going uh getting too philosophical
about these things or too theoretical is
of no practical value in fact I'm going
to argue and I'm going to try to
demonstrate that reorienting our
perception of what large language models
are and sort of re getting a sense of
what they one what really are may help
us uh focus on diff a different research
agenda than perhaps we're working on now
or perhaps to at least augment it uh so
let me begin with what I'm going to try
to do here um uh first of all I most
generally I really want to focus on the
effective large language models on the
biomedical field uh I'm going to talk
about the effective large language
models on knowledge in general and then
try to bring it down to biom Medicine
per se um and specifically how they
might affect the transfer of knowledge
uh so it's both about what you know how
it affects knowled itself and how it how
it's transferred and obviously this
includes education because education
although it's not limited to this is
clearly about the transfer of knowledge
uh intergenerationally and and and
otherwise as a caveat um you know
echoing the U the quote I just made this
is a preface that I'm providing I don't
actually have research uh Empirical
research that would be uh grounded in
what I'm going to describe I'm going to
give you a preface or what in philosophy
is called a polygon uh sort of setting
up the the the the the the setting the
table for a different kind of work uh as
I said to reorient our understanding of
large language models and so
consequently it's preliminary and
theoretical and so I just ask your
forgiveness leading getting into this uh
on that matter so the first thing is
Let's uh describe a couple of items um
uh some of the basic uh Concepts here I
assume a lot of you already know what
large language models are and language
models but I'm going to describe that
describe it anyway uh just in case you
don't so
basically a large language model is just
the latest and greatest iteration of
something that has existed existed for a
long time you can argue since the turn
of the century with marov uh there are
iterations of language models and
technically a language model is just a
statistical model that can be used to
estimate the probabilities of word
sequences um and these probabilities are
often estimated from the data uh that
you use to estimate the parameters of
these models comes from come from text
collections uh this is often described
models are often described as as models
that predict the next word uh given a
sequence of words but I feel like it's
it's better to just describe them as
estimating probabilities for a variety
of purposes because they're used to do a
couple of things broadly speaking they
can both interpret inputs and and
generate outputs of text as well um just
a side note I don't know if you guys can
see this because of my picture but um
the this XKCD comic here shows uh that a
this the large language model employed
by the woman on the right is is is not
really doing a good job because
obviously the next word or the next
letters in that sentence is not audite
it is erupt um as a side note I want to
say that uh these large language models
and language models in general are not
just a side thing you know or just a
sort of Niche kind of model within the
space of uh machine learning or in data
science they're actually Central to
information Theory um Claude Shannon in
his article is you know is well
well-known 1948 article on information
Theory um intro reintroduced the idea of
a text model and actually showed text
models as generative text models in
order to frame his discussion of
information Theory and so equally uh as
general as information theory is so are
these language models in their
applicability they've been used for
predictions of everything from nucleic
and amino acids to words and pixels
we're going to focus on words because
this is where you know large language
models have shown lately
so if you look at a large language model
just in uh in its most sort of basic
structure it looks something like this
you have a lot of input I'm talking
about a large language model and how
it's being how it's used once it's
trained it's got a lot of input
possibilities you can give it search
queries you can give it sentences to be
translated questions to be answered text
to be summarized any any number of such
things and basically these are all fed
to a common model trained According to
some um uh function such as what you see
at the top there and that generates a
search space within which you can
produce uh the following kinds of
outputs depending on what you're
inputting search responses translated
sentences and so on uh this Paradigm of
what a language model is meant to do uh
is true of language models and large
language models it's just that large
language models do them so much more
effectively if we look at large language
models I like to think of the large
language model as consisting of four
broad layers and it's interesting to
note that each of these layers each
element uh essential to the construction
of a large language model such as chat
GPT or Bard uh or actually the language
models would be uh GPT and and Bert um
these models all require these big
chunks of technology or infrastructure
that only existed relatively recently so
the first is that they they're built on
top of massive text corpora drawn from
Decades of internet use and so basically
the web has been this huge aggregator of
textural data producing corpora of a
magnitude unheard of before the the rise
of the web and the engagement of of
users in producing content on the web um
and so that one interesting thing to not
is that the condition of possibility for
these large language models is the web
itself it's almost a byproduct of the
web in some sense the second part of a
lang large language model that's
interesting which distinguishes it from
regular language models is that they
introduce novel methods for representing
textual data and really the single
there's a lot obviously that goes into
the construction of a large language
model but I would point out that the
single most important contribution was
the development of word
embeddings uh and word embeddings
alongside what are called positional
embeddings um that really provide and
we'll see this in a second all of the
information that large language model is
going to use to derive what it considers
to be meaning uh without word embeddings
you don't have large language models as
as we uh understand them today and large
language models provide the bulk of the
information that a large language model
uses the third part is that they're
neural networks they're not probalistic
models in the traditional sense they're
not other kinds of models there are
neural networks that have a huge number
of Weights uh billions or or in excess
of a trillion weights sometimes that are
uh you know trained on pred next words
as we've talked about of not just words
but higher units of discourse as well um
and again because of the internet and
the rise of massive
infrastructural uh uh technologies that
support the internet itself such as what
Google and Amazon have created it has
been able we've been able to stand up
these very very very large uh models and
train them uh which takes months to do
um and so we have the following we'll
look at a little more of these in a
second uh that we all know of the Bert
language model the GPT language model
Palm llama and so forth and finally we
have these products that uh that really
are catching our attention which is the
the the wrapping of a user interface and
a set of tasks and and some Downstream
training that makes these things act as
agents within a context and so that they
can be brought into environments and
domains such as biom medicine where
they're useful so all of those four
things um constitute what I would call
the large language model we oftentimes
focus on the uh I guess the second and
third sometimes on the first um but the
the whole thing I would I would say
suggest really constitutes what we're
talking
about now here's a graphic taken from a
an article that shows just to give you a
sense of how many large language models
have been developed since around 2019
and really we're working within a
five-year window here where things start
to get revolutionized uh the um the big
innovation in the Transformer
architecture on which these models were
made took place in
2017 and and soon thereafter these large
language models trained on the huge
corpora that we described using these
large n networks uh were developed and
so we see there's been a lot a lot of
work uh a lot a lot of output here we
tend to focus on chat GPT because it
just happened to be the most successful
uh among these the most successfully
productized um large language model uh
and you know for a lot of reasons that
historians of science would probably be
delve into it sort of you know took
center stage and it sort of captured the
imagination of everyone but there have
been a lot and there continued to be a
lot of uh large language models in
development now the thing about them
putting them in the context of um the
general practice of text Mining and
natural language processing uh it turns
out that large language models what
makes them so you know interesting and
so powerful is that they pretty much
outperform all other language models and
text mining algorithms on NLP and text
mining tasks so there are a lot of
models out there a lot of approaches to
solving things like how do we do n named
enery recognition how do we do a part of
speech tagging for example one often
uses a hidden marov model for that it
turns out that all of those tasks uh are
are are do are within the capability of
these large langu models and they tend
to to them very well so here a list of
of these uh tasks broken down into what
I call the natural language processing
side which is about language of s and
the information retrieval side which is
about working with collections of text
so I call these super models a little
bit of a t there but they really are
super in the sense of Uber or
encompassing of of all previous
models now within this field of
biomedicine uh there's been a lot of uh
work uh developing these models or
applying these models uh there have been
a lot of domain specific models
generated and I here have a short list
of those some of the more well-known
models that you'll see out there
Metatron bioert biog GPT biomed GPT and
so forth uh I have these roughly
distinguished here between those on the
top which are ones that are trained on
uh research data and what I would call
formal knowledge as I described in the
abstract and then there's on the bottom
gatron and hybert clinical Bert are
trained on what I might call informal
data doesn't mean they're they're
they're not rule based or structured
because sometimes they're trained on
things like reports medical reports and
and tests and so forth as you can see in
the second column but there is a broad
breakdown between models that are
trained on research data and those that
are trained on data that arises in the
practice of medicine which is an
interesting breakdown they tend to have
a a set of Target tasks one of the most
common is the medical question and
answer task uh another one interesting
is medical relation extraction which is
like hypothesis mining named entity
recognition messaging document
summarization and so forth and from this
a bunch of use cases uh emerge I don't
know if you can see the upper right but
I have research summarization hypothesis
mining there's education question and
answer there's effective writing uh
using them to to generate effective
writing there's automated grading that
has been explored within this domain um
and then there's stuff like you know
discharge summary writing uh composing
messages to patients uh building virtual
assistance in tele medicine and so forth
so there's just been a lot lot of work
and pretty much any any place where you
know language is used in the biomedical
domain uh you're going to find somebody
trying to develop a large language model
application for
it so oops let me go here oop sorry I'm
getting ahead so here's a a distinction
that's probably worth noting we're not
going to go into though but there are
two general approaches to creating these
large language models uh one is to say
well let's take an existing large
language model such as you know GPT and
use it as a foundation model and do some
transfer learning uh or fine-tuning uh
and add specific content from a domain
such as PubMed and then create a model
that way and then there are others who
are working vigorously to just from
scratch you know forget about building
on top of a pre-existing model with you
know you know language that's not
directly relevant to the biomedical
field and just train directly on on on
Pub Med and so you have those as well I
have a remark here in the right uh which
points out that there's been some
interesting research that shows that
generalist models without any training
at all without any you know extra
inclusion of medical uh literat for
example PBM can actually do really well
and outperform some domain specific
models on medical questioning and
answering and so there's an article here
and if you guys want if anyone wants um
um uh references I can provide those but
there these folks from Microsoft have
shown that uh that chat jpt with
prompting and we're going to get into
that a little bit later uh can actually
outperform uh these other models which
is really quite an interesting
finding here's another uh distinction to
look at here is that these large
language models uh we want to focus a
lot on how they're used in what the
upper right there the generative task of
communicating with people and letting
people interact with them through text
but they are also still being used for
good old machine learning prediction
tasks uh so uh just something to keep in
mind we're focusing on the on the uh the
top one but uh those other tasks are
being performed as well by these and
there's a lot of work as well um and
using them for these these things and
finally I just want to give you another
example again taken from an article of
how there are certain models that are
both multimodal in the sense that
they'll take they can be trained on
image data as well as Text data and they
can be used for a variety of tasks uh
such as the ones we just saw above the
the uh generative one of of of
interacting with people but also doing a
lot of classification and prediction as
well so they're in this sense as well
they're they're super models they're
they're kind of allpurpose they they're
they're they're kind of being positioned
to do lots of different
things all right so we've all a lot
heard a lot of hype about these we've
probably used them probably you know our
Jaws have dropped in certain context
using them and so forth but we've also
read about um some of the concerns and
so even though they've been proven
effective at you know passing medical
exams doing extremely well on medical
exams translating technical diagnoses to
patients summarizing research documents
and so forth
they do have shortcomings in the area of
knowledge and reasoning and I I cite
three uh examples uh of of these uh
shortcomings the first one is what is
out of context learning so large
language models do really well when
they're asked questions about stuff that
is in the context of the Corpus on which
they were trained but if you try to
generalize out of that they they don't
do so well in fact a lot of times when
they work with out of context or what we
used to call out of sample uh d
uh they will produce hallucinations they
will just blly just generate text that
is completely false both from a factual
perspective but also uh from an
authoritative perspective in other words
it might site sources that don't exist
site sources that look like articles uh
but aren't but aren't to be found
anywhere in the world um and more
recently we've discovered that they have
are called logic what have been called
logical inference failures uh something
called the reversal curse if you train a
large language model on uh the
proposition a is B uh or if you if you
um you know if it successfully answers
that question uh it doesn't necessarily
know the opposite that b is a uh and so
all of these things and others as well
and this is all in addition to the bias
questions and the Privacy questions that
are sort of go without saying I think at
this point in time there are
accountability concerns uh for these
models basically uh if you read the
literature a recurring theme is that
biomedical professionals and
stakeholders basically want to know if
these things can be trusted and
oftentimes the languages can they be
trusted like colleagues I mean can we
just treat them like colleagues and
submit them to the same sorts of
expectations and uh and and uh
punishments and rewards that we give to
our colleagues about you know getting
things right and wrong so how can we do
this um just a quick uh drill down on
the reversal course here's an example um
you know you can it can answer correctly
who is Tom Cruz's mother and give the
answer you know Mary Lee feifer but then
if you ask who is Mary Le Fifer's son it
doesn't really give you an answer um it
this is an interesting question too
because the answer who is Mary Le
Fifer's son could have more than there
could be more than one answer to that
but even with that it's just basically
saying I I don't know and we know that
it actually has uh implicitly in in some
kind of latent way it it actually kind
of knows the answer but it's not able to
produce it okay I I want to make a quick
aside on this though um it's I think
it's a little bit unfair to ask language
models to do this uh and we'll see in a
second why and that's because they don't
possess an ontology and uh what's often
misunderstood about logic is that
logical any logical problem even the
syllogisms from you know uh you know the
old Scholastic syllogisms uh from the
Middle Ages they all require an ontology
uh they assume an ontology underneath
and these models do not have an ontology
that connects the words in the model to
uh connections and so for example if you
look at the right here this is what you
might need to have uh built into the
model uh to make it be able to do things
like that it must have at some level
some some way in which it defines these
these uh inverse or reciprocal relations
as as as mapped onto each other and what
we see on the right are the way that is
expressed in a specific specific
ontology language called Owl uh using a
uh a syntax called rdf but we're not
going to go into this this this will
come up a little bit later but just a
side
note so this question of trust then you
know how can we build trust in large
language models um what will it take to
treat them as colleagues as we as uh has
been expressed very often in the
criticism of these models in the
biomedical field there's a term that's
out there to capture this expectation
which is an interesting reversal of the
usual word of human in the loop is that
we want AI in the loop which to my mind
repeats an old Mantra of having
technology on tap but not on top how can
we actually you know sort of maybe the
word is domesticate these so they can be
incorporated into our working
environment the way that we incorporate
our professional colleagues and so our
our current approaches to doing this are
a couple we have you know alignment via
reinforcement learning from Human
feedback uh
rlf we have the uh expectation or or
sort of the desire to make these models
explainable and there are a lot of tools
to help do that uh there's some
interesting work on uh treating
explainability as as dialogue in other
words uh not just like opening up the
hood of a of a neural network and sort
of seeing what it's you know basically
looking at when it makes a a decision
but actually getting these neural
networks to uh explain themselves like
if you ask it you know why did you why
did you do that it could give you the
answer but I'm going to argue that a lot
of these uh approaches uh solutions to
this problem based are based on hidden
assumptions I would call them even folk
models about large language models and
AI in general uh which um you know I
think deserves some scrutiny so you know
we should ask ourselves you know are are
the contents of a black box enough uh to
to to make such uh such tools or
machines uh
accountable um and more generally you
know our whole framing of this ethical
question or this practical question is
to treat them as agents treat them as
professionals are they really analogous
to agents uh or I mean they are agents
in the narrow sense of that term but are
they really analogous to people as
agents as we normally think of them and
and this idea of AI and the loop you
know what what are we talking about when
we're talking about this Loop what does
that Loop actually look like and is that
Loop restructured uh by these large
language models in ways that we can't
really see there are a number of
questions here but um basically I'm just
sort of setting up this idea that we can
problematize the the approaches that we
we have and it and and take a kind of
critical spec perspective at what
assumptions they're making about
knowledge so to build trust I'm going to
argue is that we need to understand
large language models relation to
knowledge uh we assume they possess
knowledge and intelligence uh but
historians of science uh have shown that
you know we've always overestimated the
capabilities and qualities of
interactive machinery from the beginning
we've attributed intentionality to them
and not just lay people but but
developers as well um and it's
interestingly the case as Lucy suchman
argues that the opacity of these systems
actually encourage us to do this um and
so what we really want to do is focus on
something that philosophers call
justification so if we want to say that
large language models possess knowledge
we want to we want to make sure that
they possess Justified true belief okay
uh and this is a a traditional sort of
uh I will say undergraduate
understanding about knowledge if you get
you know into philosophy itself there's
some very sophisticated rebuttal or
developments of this idea but we'll
stick to this this is good uh it's
Justified true belief and the idea the
reason we say knowledge is more than
just true belief is that sometimes
people can be correct by accident right
you can you can predict the outcome of
of a game or the weather uh and be
correct but it doesn't mean you knew uh
knew about the weather or the game you
just you just kind of got lucky in some
cases doesn't matter if you survive
based on that decision but we want more
than that right good luck is not a good
long-term
strategy so let's look at this in a
little bit more detail typically
justification normally entails
understanding the process by which a
claim is made in math we have proofs in
science we have reproducibility in law
we have I guess I'll call it logical
validity relative to code of law and
precedent and religion we have appeal to
interpretive Authority relative to
sacred texts and traditions in almost
any domain uh in which knowledge of some
kind is is uh is promoted distributed
consumed there are Cannons of of
justification and so given the opacity
of llms what what can we provide for
justification of their claims so one
common approach uh and I think this is
sort of the uh the uh assumed approach
of most people who develop them and who
have sort of you know taken the red pill
if you will of machine learning and not
worried about whether you understand the
model um is is is you know just
pragmatism if something works it's true
but I'm going to argue that this is
unsatisfying because we in order to um
arrive at an understanding of knowledge
that gives us trust we need to know why
and how something works and you know as
we mentioned earlier we want llms to be
able to explain themselves to us and not
just say look it worked uh don't worry
about
it so the approach then I'm going to
take uh is this uh and uh just two
general questions one is what is the
relationship between large language
models and language and the second is
what is the relation relationship
between language and knowledge and from
there we can uh make an assessment of
how large language models are related to
knowledge and then uh proceed and
interact with them in a more uh accurate
way so I'm going to begin with this
quote here for this section that I think
is it's funny but true every time I fire
a linguist the performance of the speech
recognizer goes up this is attributed to
a an IBM uh U uh scientist or engineer
I'm not quite sure Frederick galenic uh
this is one of these quotes that has a
lot of different uh attributions of
context uh but it it's it's it's used a
lot and it captures an interesting fact
about the history of language model
development is that the language models
that we have today were not built on any
linguist understanding of language at
least at the time right because at the
time during the 70s say when these
things are being developed in 80s
chomskian Linguistics held the day and
this older kind of linguistics uh more
statistical based associated with say
zelig Harris was out of favor and so uh
these models are developed interestingly
by a much older understanding of how
language should be studied and that
particular theory of language is
captured under the concept of the
distributional hypothesis and basically
the distributional hypothesis says that
the meaning of a word can be inferred
from its context okay uh raym I should
say F not first Raymond F uh put it this
way that you shall know a word by the
company it keeps um and L Vicken Stein
the great philosopher in the early 20th
century basically had the same idea by
saying look when we understand the
meanings of words we don't want to
necessarily look at how the their
connection to the world we simply know
need to know what the meaning of a word
is in its use and so this idea of of
meaning has been operationalized uh uh
uh by the the distribution hypothesis
has been operationalized in the concept
of word embeddings so word embeddings
basically capture the statistical
distributions properties of words in
their context and that provides all of
the meaning uh that llms use to generate
the outputs that it generates um these
these llms actually refine these
embeddings during training making them
more context specific and more powerful
but basically it's still working on word
embeddings and word embeddings are just
operationalizations of the disal
hypothesis
the important thing to note here is that
at no point are these models uh working
with with the referential function of
language they're they're never ever uh
connecting words to things in the world
it's not it's hard to even imagine how
they could do that or to implicit
ontologies as I mentioned earlier it's
purely a horizontal if you will
statistical uh uh operation of capturing
which words go together with which other
words so this is a quick graphic to show
you how the data are generated at least
just the word embeddings which are used
to map onto sentences which are then fed
into language models uh if you take this
sentence the quick brown fox jumped over
the lazy dogs the way that we would
gather the meaning of the terms in a
corpus full of sentences like this is to
take each word in a given sentence and
Associate it with its context uh defined
as the previous two words and the
following two words and that and that's
a hyper parameter that you can very
uh and you can see that that that the
text on the left can be converted in the
text on the right you can see that each
word is associated with four other words
uh and so you have like a little mini
bag of words if you will and then that
gets compressed or or or understood
statistically and is used to train a
neural network that produces these
weights and so every single word then in
a in a vocabulary associated with a
corpus will then have a number of
Weights associated with a number of
features fees that the neural network uh
uh you know produced as a result of
training um and so just to just to
reinforce the point that that's all that
we're doing to to understand the meaning
of words we're not doing anything else
we're not connecting them to ontologies
we're not connecting them to things in
the
world um and so it's an interesting
question at this point that you know are
language our large language models
language models of course they are
language models but say from an outside
perspective from a linguist perspective
are they language models I would arue in
a certain sense they're not because they
do not operationalize grammar-based
theories of language and a lot of
linguists think that's what language is
if you ask nom Chomsky or Steph Pinker
they're going to tell you that's what
language is language is essentially
grammar and uh the discursive dimension
of language is is is an epiphenomenal
aspect of it um I would also argue that
they're not language models in the in
the sense of um of of models statistical
models because they're unseparable from
their data and it's a Criterion you you
know for ideally a model should be
completely separable from its data data
should be used to estimate parameters
and then you should be able to throw the
data away and you can't do that with
large language models they are
intrinsically bound up with the data
that are used to train
them um so this leads us to the question
of well how they relate to knowledge if
if if if if if a large language model is
trained on this particular conception of
meaning uh and this conception of
meaning has nothing to do with reference
then what does that mean for knowledge
so I'm going to quote Richard fman here
uh who's not a philosopher of science
but who's a great scientist uh uh about
some really basic distinction that he's
been known to to make which I think
makes a lot of sense and here it's
captured in this idea um about a bird
you can know the name of a bird in all
languages of the world but when you're
finished you'll know absolutely nothing
whatever about the bird so let's look at
the bird and what it's doing that's what
counts I learned very early the
difference between knowing the name of
something and knowing something so
that's an important distinction there
between knowing the name of something
and knowing something knowing something
requires actually engaging with the
thing itself that's referred to and of
course llms don't do that so if the
authentic knowledge if authentic
knowledge requires application of the
referential function of language then
llms do not possess knowledge in this
sense they know the names of things but
not things in themselves so if we think
of experience and experiment as
essential conditions for epistemic
justification in biomedicine then llm
sentences they don't justify the
condition of Justified true belief so we
might want to say they don't know
anything but this is unsatisfying
right so what are they what are they
actually then you know what where do
they derive their power from well I'm
going to argue that they are not
language models per se and I know this
is a little bit of a rhetorical
provocation because you can always say
yes they are in a very narrow technical
sense I call them uh discourse uh models
they're discourse engines because they
model discourse and I'll explain what
that means means in a second they
predict and generate sentences without
the intermediary of a grammar they are
generative concordances I would call
them generative recombinant concordances
of text corpora on which they are
trained and so the thing I'd like to
emphasize is that they possess knowledge
to the extent that knowledge is
linguistically constituted and this is
an important concept we're going to look
at in a second so it follows that
they're best study to the lens of the of
fields that focus on discourse so this
is this is the great shifting of
attention I'd like to to make here is to
shift our attention from language in the
sense that you might have learned in in
in in college you know and studying
chsky or whatever onto language as
discourse which is more how
anthropologists have studied language
over the last few
decades and so the idea then back to
trust if llms are discourse engines I.E
not based on rules ontologies or
experience then how can we assess the
effects on knowledge and
education um and basically I'm just argu
doing that in order to trust them we
have to understand what they know and
how they know and the best way to look
at this is through uh their their the
relationship between discourse and
knowledge which we'll look at in a
second or actually right
now so getting back to
um uh uh zel Harris here who's the uh
who created the distributional
hypothesis the first sort of scientific
formulation of it in his book discourse
analysis we may not know just what a
text is saying but we can discover how
it is saying it what are the patterns of
recurrence of its chief for morphing so
just just reiterating the distribution
hypothesis and noting that it is closely
associated with the concept of discourse
and then you have the philosopher Paul
rur who says that the Linguistics of
discourse has different rules in the
Linguistics of language so what are
those different
rules so the basic distinction I want to
make here I just wanted to bring to your
attention which is fundamental to the
study of language it goes back to the uh
early 20th century when ferdan Cur who's
in the first col column makes a
distinction between long and parole he's
French and so that's language and speech
chsky describes these as the difference
between competence and performance uh I
I called them the difference between
grammar and discourse and large language
models as we've just seen focus on level
two and they do not make any reference
to level one at all we may think that
they are learning those in the weights
of these massive neural networks but
it's hard to call a trillion parameter
entity a grammar uh that's that that
would be crazy if you handed someone a
grammar of of a language and it had a
trillion uh Pages as it were um so L
large language models operate to the
level of discourse not
Grammar and when we talk about discourse
what are we talking about here is a
model of discourse that that is is
fundamental to its study it basically
points out that all uh uh discourse is
composed of sentences that's the
elementary unit of discourse and every
sentence is ideally a speech act or
utterance that occurs in a situation and
that situation has the elements of
someone who's speaking someone who's
listening a common situation that they
share it could be a clinic it could be a
a something a lab and then there's the
instance meaning it happened at a
particular place and time uh this is
what we mean by discourse uh we can
actually organize the the study of uh
you know text Mining and national
language processing the particular uh
activities Within These Fields according
to these categories defined by this
understanding of
discourse um but what I want to do here
in the in the time limited time that I
have going forward is just to point out
that if you look at language this way as
discourse and you look at the elementary
structure of discourse what emerges is
that it's it's always social discourse
is always embedded in Social
relations uh because there's always a
speaker and a listener and that speaker
and listener have a relationship to each
other it could be a power relationship
it could be a working relationship it
could be a kinship relationship um and
the field that has been devoted uh with
these adjacent Fields below to the study
of language and discourse is socio
Linguistics uh which studies the
relation relationship between language
and society and culture and I'll point
out these other fields as well discourse
analysis ethnomethodology anthropology
of language and the ethnography of
speaking so here are some findings uh
from this field uh discourse encodes
social relations anytime two people
speak the actual grammar of their
sentences the actual diction of those
sentences will indexically reflect the
relationship that they have uh sometimes
this is explicitly uh developed in say
in the case of the military and
sometimes it's implicit in the kind of
language relationships we develop with
people um discourse is always situated
in a place in time it has a situation it
has it implies a shared world or an
antology AS we saw earlier discourse
also always occurs within a discourse
Community discourse comes in discourse
genres in other words there're different
kinds of discourse depending on the
relationship between people you can
broadly distinguish between informal and
informal modes of discourse and finally
discourse operates within a a a a
network uh of communication so you can
think of discourse if you think of a
graph you know and a common sort of you
know image that you get from social
network analysis of different nodes
communicating with each other at each
one of those edges is is is discourse
and those discourse uh uh those
conversations that are being had are
going to be had in a certain way uh
they're going to have certain qualities
by virtue of the nature of the
relationship by which that they
mediate so um quick Point here this is a
a really uh important point it's got a
lot of depth to it but I'm just going to
quickly go over it uh a li over it just
to get to the next point which is that
when we look at discourse language as
discourse engines we see immediately
that they don't possess these traits
they they actually don't uh understand
anything about the shared situation
between speaker and listener they don't
have a shared world we tal we just saw
that that they don't have an ontology
and so forth what do they have though is
something that is in common with writing
so uh the thing
about what we're looking at you know the
kind of data on which these models are
train is that they are it's all based on
written uh uh text right this is uh
obvious but what what we have to
understand is that
writing is a form of discourse that
detaches language from its context of
use and therefore it transforms all of
the dimensions of the elementary
structure of of of discourse that we
looked at and and produces these really
interesting Transformations that make
text what's they are in other words it
gives them the power that they have uh
for to for to to to convey knowledge
over time and space and so forth and uh
can't get into that too deeply here it's
basically the basis of a field called
hermeneutics but the idea is that we
have with our our written discourse on
which large language models are based we
we have a a kind of discourse which I'll
call non-referential discourse so
non-referential discourse is is is the
discourse spoken language say captured
and WR wrting doesn't always have to
begin with with speech but it's captured
in writing it's detached from a
situation and so what what remains from
that sort of if you will the fossil
remains of discourse in text is is uh is
basically the linguistic forms that are
used to have
conversations and I'm I'm actually
reading from the slide here I'm kind of
jumping ahead in the interest of
time what I want to say is that even
though large language models do not
possess specific spefic utterances you
know used that are taken from a
particular context they do transmit and
generate knowledge of a certain kind um
and let me describe this here so a large
part of
education is acquiring the vocabulary
and the idioms of a domain language
independently of The Facts of that field
so a large part of knowledge exists not
in specific claims and facts but in
forms of language that make those claims
possible so following the work of
dellheim
we can call this kind of knowledge
communicative competence so what I'm
saying here is that what what a large
language model is capturing and it's
doing this uh based on uh it it inherits
the same limitations that writing
inherits from being separated from the
context of its use uh it it takes that
and then it it decomposes that into a
combinatorial logic of of of of of of of
linguistic usage patterns that are
common in those particular uh texts what
you remain what what remains is a kind
of ability to use language uh
independently of its connection to the
world and that may not seem like
knowledge in fact Richard fainman uh
Likens that kind of when when people
possess just communicative competence
like they can talk like scientists we
sometimes call that scientism he refers
to that in one of his famous speeches at
Caltech uh graduating class at Caltech
as as a cargo C where where the outer
form of science is is learned but the
actual engagement with reality and
understanding of how it works is not
learned but this is not actually this is
a little bit unfair uh because
um because we do know that a large part
of of becoming educated is learning how
to speak a certain way and learning the
idioms and the vocabulary of a
particular field when you become
educated in that particular field a ton
of it like a huge percentage of what
you're learning isn't direct knowledge
of the world but all the linguistic
apparatus required to actually engage in
a professional Community to do that kind
of research um and that's what large
language models capture and so what I
would like to propose is that in order
to understand large language models
authentically we ought to be looking at
them through the lens of language
socialization and so language
socialization is a concept that comes
from anthropology uh was originally uh
focused on looking at how language is
learned by children in communities
around the world and the basic finding
is that basically children become
enculturated and socialized through
language learning in other words when
you learn language you're not just
learning how to speak you're learning
how to be a person in a particular
culture you're learning a whole bunch of
things about modes of behavior about
orientation of Mind toward the world and
these things come in the form of of
heavily encoded uh grammatically encoded
language that you possess and that you
you then carry forward and that you
employ in various contexts and so this
is what I want to argue is that um let
me see if I can go here that um if we
look at education as a particular kind
of language socialization learning the
specific languages of a discipline
including both formal bodies of
knowledge and informal ways of knowing
uh we can see that this is precisely
what large language models are modeling
so just to repeat they're not modeling
even though sometimes they look like
they're doing it uh a body of knowledge
what they're modeling
are modes of speaking ways of speaking
uh that are associated with the practice
of of acquiring knowledge and using
knowledge and so let me Jump Ahead here
because I I just have a couple of
minutes um we can see that language
socialization in in
biomedicine uh uh takes place in in in
different context we have at least two
contexts that we should pay attention to
one is the formal context of where you
know
being engaged with the research
community and there is informal context
where you're say in the context of
practice where you're working with
patients Dr doctor communication Dr
patient communication and we have
language models associated with each of
these um what I want to point out is
that where this comes to a head where
you can really apply the concept of
language socialization to large language
models in the context of biomedicine is
in the area of prompt engineering Ing
and it it's no accident that you know
prompt engineering has emerged to be the
most active area of development and and
uh and and training if you will in the
use of large language models uh it's in
prom engineering that you are engaged
with the language model uh and
understanding how it speaks as it were
and getting and and understanding how
the the the language model speaks and
understanding how to condition it on
certain speech forms improve proves the
productiveness and the effectiveness of
those models right so it's precisely in
becoming familiar with what uh uh we
called earlier communicative competence
like how to speak for a certain kind of
knowledge that these models actually
shine become most
productive and so there's been a lot of
work on on large language models uh and
prompting in the context of biomedicine
uh it's being touted as an essential
form of knowledge that that you should
have in order to practice medicine going
forward uh and you know essentially a
primary
skill and I've just got some like these
are some examples of of uh prompting
strategies that I'm going to skip over
here what I want to do is stop at this
slide and just simply point out that
what is happening is that um here on the
left you see a well-known sort of cheat
sheet on how to uh prompt and interact
with a with a medical GPT this is a one
specific to the biomedical space and to
me this looks a lot like Strunk and
white or something like that it's it's
basically teaching you how to speak
language so the question I have is
although prompt engineering is
ostensibly another means of training a
language model uh in another sense
prompt engineering is a way of training
us to interact with the large language
model so we are being trained in a
particular form of discourse in order to
make these tools more effective in our
particular context and so the question
that I have you know the challenge that
I have and I'll conclude here let me see
if I can get this to change is that
given that you know the kind of
knowledge that large language models
provide which is communicative
competence even though they do in
practice you know effectively Pro they
work as information retrieval devices as
well but really what at the core they're
giving us communitive competence and
given that the role that large language
play in the biomedical space as primary
agents in both formal and informal
knowledge transmission via prompt and
response dialogues prompt engineering
what kind of socialization is being
placed so this is the research question
that I would put before you what are
students learning when their acquisition
of knowledge depends on their prompt
engineering expertise and what are the
effects uh intended and
unintended on the biomedical Fields uh
when every significant relationship is
mediated by this process and so I'm
going to stop right there given in time
and I do apologize for skipping over you
know some of the important elements of
this argument uh but in order to make
the argument it is necessary to go into
some of these other fields which I
expect the audience probably doesn't
have a lot of familiarity with socio
Linguistics hermeneutics and things like
that but I hope I have been able to
convey the idea that proper study of
large language models is through the
study of discourse and one of the most
fruitful ways of looking at discourse in
particular looking at large language
models to the extent that they're
employed as chat Bots and so forth is
through this concept of of of language
socialization and so I'll stop right
there thank you ref that was fantastic
uh what a great overview of large
language models and kind of how they're
built and what they can do and don't do
um it's kind of interesting because when
you you know the term model is used and
it's so much different than I think how
a lot of people think of what one does
when they're modeling you know this is a
probabilistic tree of you know if you
say this the next they must next most
likely word is this and you're basically
you're doing you're traversing a tree
but it's not really a model like we
would typically view a model and
anything that's has weights with you
know a billion parameters is you know
you've got more parameters than perhaps
you have words in your Corpus you know
it's like having a map where you know
one inch equals one in you know I'm
curious about do you ever see some
degree of I guess compression or
something where actual modeling does get
applied to make it more compactified um
but I I'm not exactly sure if this
question is accurate or not but you ever
see where the modeling would actually
play a role here well there is hope
there well you know the word model is
probably one of the most uh ambiguous
words in science because every field
uses it differently and even within
Fields it's used differently yeah um but
but let's just be very generous and
ecumenical about that word uh if you
look at the uh the Transformer
architecture uh or let's say the encoder
decoder architecture you look in the
middle of it there is you know a codec
there is a you know what's called a code
which is where you've taken all of the
input and you've compressed it into some
very reduced representation that is then
used to to produce its outputs the there
is hope and and belief that in that in
that stuff you're going to find
something like what linguists hope a
grammar or you know expect what a
grammar would be but I would argue that
it's it's we're not going to end up
getting transformational rules out of
that something like what Chomsky was
looking for or something like with you
know other grammarians uh folks looking
at rule-based understandings of language
what we're going to see is some
representation of a complex system that
is both psychological and
sociological uh and it's going to re I
think it's going to reorient our
understanding of language if we really
take it seriously my view is that
grammars don't exist in the sense that
we want them to exist there is something
grammar like that's that's durably
installed in the human brain that makes
us able to speak but a good part of what
we think of as language as a totality
also come some interactive patterns
socially people monitoring each other
having grammars uh that are explicit and
so forth that you know are written down
in books that monitor and construct our
speech and so forth so we're going to
end up with a complex understanding of
what that is I don't know if that
answers your question but yeah there is
there is something in there in in these
models that we uh in these U large
language model models that are in
another sense of model model like that
we hope to be able to excavate but I'm
thinking that when we when we actually
get to that point they're not going to
look like what we were hoping for I
liked the thing you touched on there
towards the end of of prompt engineering
and how you know maybe in the past you
know maybe like two years ago when you
know you'd open up your Google uh you
know search bar and you'd say you know
show me you know I don't know NFL
statistics or I don't know you know and
you'd get out whatever hap the the
internet happened to provide for you but
with these chat GPT and other large
language models you actually need to
craft those very specifically and that's
a skill set that uh you know you showed
a number of books that people have
developed on this which uh I think is is
fascinating that um you now we're going
to have to learn a language in order to
use these language you know generative
language systems like this I I find that
fascinating can you say a littleit more
about that yeah I mean that's where all
the action is right now is uh in in
Industry folks trying to make you know
business models out of this uh work
within biomedicine within medical
education and even within the training
of language models one of the things
that has been learned is that a lot of
stuff that happens in reinforcement
learning the RL HF stuff can actually be
done at the very end with with prompt
engineering or even as we saw from the
Microsoft research I mentioned very
briefly you know you don't even need you
because these models are trained on so
much data you don't even need to do uh
domain specific
fine-tuning uh on these models in order
to get them to pass medical exams you
just have to prompt them properly yeah
and so what that's doing is exploiting
this this property that these models
have is which they've captured all forms
of of of linguistic interaction so when
you prompt a model you know you you you
you introduce these indexical things
that we would call in Social Linguistics
like formal and informal like you know I
want you to speak formally and as a
scientist and to an audience that has
these properties you'll notice that in
prompt engineering what you're doing is
you are itemizing all of the elements of
the discourse situation that we
described at least that's a big part of
it and in addition you're you're you're
you're you're you're introducing things
like task uh uh patterns like I want you
to give me a recipe or I want you to go
step byep chain of reasoning uh but
essentially what you're doing when
you're prompting is introducing all of
these what we would call sociolinguistic
uh dimensions of language in order to
get it to focus on that area of the
Corpus that's relevant to you so this to
me reinforces the idea that what is
actually modeling our you know these
communicative competencies and it's
getting us to be more intentional about
our understanding and use of these
communicative competencies in
interacting with the models but the cost
I would argue is that we uh may be
training ourselves to to think of
knowledge in a certain way uh and there
may be some exclusions and in
conclusions you know strengths and
weaknesses that we should pay attention
to when we walk into this uh new kind of
um language situation in our last minute
or so that we have here um I want to get
you to opine a little bit about how
biomedical education could benefit from
things like prompt engineering or
understanding a little bit more deeply
about what these language
models have embodied and what some of
their strengths and weaknesses are but
how to use them as an effective tool for
you know uh I don't know ingesting
clinical notes and generating corpuses
um and you know some of the other
examples you gave in the beginning about
you know chat Bots with um with with
with patience and that sort of thing
what are some things that you know
people need to think about as we're
building
educational programs to train this next
Generation where these language large
language models are just going to be
ubiquitous
well there are to me this is uh a
question that applies to education in
general and and how how they're being
used uh and um I would defer there's
some really good research on this I hate
to just say Google that's not what I'm
saying good articles about people
specifically in medical education uh
using you know medical question and
answering uh
paradigms uh and document summarization
paradigms to to to work in the
educational field I'll just point out
that you know right now there's an
ongoing um um you know challenge uh in
all educational spaces about the way in
which we incorporate them into into our
education and the and the best practice
that seems to be emerging is is to use
this metaphor again is kind of as a
colleague a kind of sparring partner to
help you learn Concepts uh with the idea
that at the end of the day you should be
able to on your feet be able to answer
questions without the aid of of a tool
like this so a lot of the the question
and response you know setting you know
how people used to make index cards for
themselves flash cards think about that
on steroids uh that's one kind of
example uh asking there's an interesting
one uh Mo prompt uh engineering pattern
where you do roll reversal where instead
of you you uh asking questions of the
the chatbot you ask it to ask you
questions you say okay I want you to
reverse roles I want you to ask me
questions to answer a problem or to
pursue a particular line of reasoning
and that has been shown to be you know
by those who are you know interested in
pursuing this and maybe there's a little
bias there uh to being effective in in
in in in medical education um I I I can
provide you know a syllabus or a kind of
uh you know curated list of I what I
think are the best articles on this and
there are a couple of them with there
some really Salient examples but that's
one that comes to mind is this reversal
role and also thinking of in terms of
the broader field of Education where
we're all facing this problem well Raph
Alvarado from the University of Virginia
thank you so much for giving us this
overview of large language models again
what they can do can't do and uh kind of
what they're representing um this was
really fascinating and I really
appreciate you taking the time to kind
of go through with this um thank you to
everyone who joined us once again happy
New Year and uh we'll see you again next
week thanks everyone have a great
weekend thank you Ral thank you Jack